[Music]
because of coronavirus they are not
burying people in any cemetery around
carabao they can only bury them here
people from other places come here
because no cemetery can take them
the only ones that can are paid
cemeteries but if you don't have money
what can you do
people come from all over the caraballo
district
the part down below is for people who
have died of other causes
and this part up here is for those who
had current virus
[Music]
my two sons arrived at caitanya radio
clinic this is where they died
they told me there weren't intensive
care beds those are for people who have
money
there is no salvation for poor people
there is none
[Music]
you